[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
major news and britney spears's
conservatorship battle with her father
he is choosing to step down but spears's
fight for freedom isn't over what's next
and r kelly's latest request before
trial the singer's defense attorneys
want testimony accusing r kelly of
spreading herpes to young women kept out
of court a judge officially drops one of
the charges against harvey weinstein the
disgraced producer now facing 10 sex
crimes plus is robert durst gearing up
to point the finger at another possible
murderer for the death of his best
friend susan berman and i said
susie susie it's bobby pick up the phone
and the punishment is dead a convicted
cop killer to be executed for murdering
a sheriff's deputy and sending fire to
his body law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin following a public war of words
britney spears's father agrees to step
down as conservator of her estate it's
something the pop star has wanted for
months lawn crimes angenette levy is
here with the latest and what spears
lawyer has to say
yeah brian jamie spears says he is
willing to step down but didn't give a
timeline for when he may do so now
britney spears his lawyer is declaring
victory but he says this is not over
britney spears is getting her wish her
father jamie is willing to step down as
conservator of her estate after 13 years
in new court documents jamie spears
attorneys wrote he does not believe a
public battle with his daughter would be
in her best interest and while he
objects to the petition for his removal
he said he intends to work with the
court and his daughter's new attorney to
prepare for an orderly transition to a
new conservator california attorney dina
dahl has been following the case
he conceded without admitting that he
should be removed that it was the right
thing to do i say free you think me free
britney spears's fans have launched a
movement to support her desire to end
the conservatorship her father's
willingness to step down came after a
war of words with the conservator of
britney spears's person jody montgomery
jamie spears claiming montgomery felt
britney needed to be placed in a
psychiatric facility in june but
montgomery's lawyer fired back in a
statement saying at no time did ms
montgomery express to mr spears that ms
spears would currently qualify for such
a hold montgomery said she told jamie
she believed forcing ms spears to take
the stand to testify or to have her
evaluated would move the needle in the
wrong direction for her mental health
attorney dave ring's take well miss
montgomery comes back and says wait a
minute i never said that i never said
that at all i said i had some concerns
about brittany's mental health i never
said they were that extreme i think it
makes
jamie spears
i think it makes him look bad hours
after jamie spears said he was willing
to step down britney spears posted this
photo on instagram without a caption her
attorney matthew rosengart calling this
a major victory for britney spears and
another step toward justice he went on
to say we look forward to continuing our
vigorous investigation into the conduct
of mr spears and others over the past 13
years while he reaped millions of
dollars from his daughter's estate and i
look forward to taking mr spears's sworn
deposition in the near future
rosengart wants forensic accountant
jason rubin appointed as conservator one
of the
um allegations that he is apparently
going to make is that the dad jamie
spears
improperly used some of britney spears
money because that's the only reason to
have a forensic accountant come in and
account for all the money
jamie spears was incredibly defiant in
his court filing he said the things he
did were to protect his daughter's
well-being and her reputation he also
said that if people knew the extent of
the issues his daughter has had over the
years they would be praising him the
next court hearing for this case is on
september 29th brian
thanks angenet joining us today is judge
susan chris and terry austin your honor
jamie spears said he would step down
when the time is right but as you heard
he asserted there's no reasonable
explanation for his removal do you think
that this decision is based even in
small part to the free brittany movement
absolutely as well as the fact that she
has a good aggressive attorney and now
her dad has to do damage control for
himself
i think that i think there's strong
evidence that he has enriched himself to
her detriment and he realizes that's
coming out
yeah all those accounting and those
numbers are going to be very interesting
to see when they come to light to see
how that money was moved and if he did
at least illegally or wrongfully enrich
himself terry if or when jamie steps
down does that then create a smoother
transition or process for ending the
conservatorship
it will pave the way to end the
conservative chef this is a step-by-step
process remember jamie was both in
charge of the personal finances and her
personal decisions about what she can do
with herself basically and so he was
removed as her personal conservator and
jody montgomery as we heard was replaced
and
she works very closely jody does with
brittany and with britney's mom and i
think that they will be able to work
with the conservator and be able to
ultimately end it and if you have a cpa
who's certified and working on the
financial side you have jody montgomery
working on the personal side i think
ultimately this new attorney who is very
savvy and does know what he's doing i
think ultimately he will be able to get
the entire conservative ship end it all
together yeah you won't have jamie
spears there pushing back as a
conservator of the estate so plus
probably a lot easier and jeanette
wasn't there uh some news recently about
the judge presiding over the case
yeah there was an interesting bit of
news kind of a disturbing bit of news
actually judge brenda penny has been
presiding over this case for many years
and she has been receiving some death
threats and other types of threats
according to
um
actually
she's been receiving threats i can't i
don't know if they were death threats
but she's been receiving those threats
and the la county sheriff's office is
monitoring those so there is a lot of
passion surrounding this case and it
seems that some people are taking their
passions and their anger out on the
judge which it probably is not the right
thing to do in this case
yeah definitely not the right thing and
i think judge chris will agree with me
not the right thing to take it out on a
judge in such a such a case uh obviously
keep an eye out on the conservative chef
for britney spears because this is just
one of many steps as it continues
towards what we believe will be the
ending of britney spears conservatorship
turning now to another development ahead
of the start of r kelly's trial in new
york the singer's attorneys want
testimony accusing him of spreading
herpes to young woman kept out of the
court
defense attorneys for r kelly are asking
the judge to not allow jane doe 11 to
testify she believes r kelly has herpes
as early as 2003 because she says she
contracted it from him according to
court documents another accuser also
plans to testify she contracted herpes
from r kelly in 2009. r kelly's
attorneys say by allowing such testimony
in by a layperson as proof that r kelly
had herpes in 2003 would be to
circumvent the requirement of having an
expert testify as to whether or not mr
kelly had herpes a jury of seven men and
five women have been selected to hear
the case opening statements are set to
begin next wednesday
still ahead on law and crime daily a
woman accused of killing her grandmother
and her grandmother's boyfriend where
their bodies were later found but first
harvey weinstein gains a legal victory
why the disgraced producer will be
facing one less charge and one less
accuser when he stands trial in los
angeles next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to
youtubetv today and then locate lawn
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle watch lawn crime every day
with youtube tv we put you in the jury
box
[Music]
welcome back convicted rapist harvey
weinstein has officially scored one
legal win a judge has affirmed her
decision to drop one of the 11 charges
against the disgraced movie producer
there was no merit to count count five
the judge officially dropped count five
which accused weinstein of sexual
battery by restraint against a woman in
may 2010. that brings the number of
accusers in the indictment down to four
we expect that the defect in the
prosecution's case on all the counts and
all the the jane doe's allegations are
going to be revealed weinstein was
initially charged in january 2020 six
months later he was indicted by a grand
jury judge lisa lynch ruled that
prosecutors had not informed the grand
jury that in those six months the
allegation had fallen outside the
10-year statute of limitations
prosecutors disagreed this superseding
indictment
that we've obtained in this case is a
continuation of everything that we've
done before david ring represents one of
weinstein's los angeles accusers she
testified at the grand jury proceedings
and ring says she's prepared to testify
again when weinstein goes to trial she's
hanging in there it's been tough it's
been a long haul and it's
you know she's she's still very
fearful of harvey weinstein and she's
very anxious about the process but she
is going to see it through the former
movie mogul still faces 10 charges he's
due back in court next month
let's bring back judge chris and terry
austin discuss this minor legal victory
for harvey weinstein terry even though
this charge and this alleged victim's
accusations are thrown out could the
prosecution still use these allegations
against weinstein
it's possible brian but i don't think
that's going to happen i mean the judge
could allow it but what the judge has to
decide here is it more probative that it
is prejudicial and whether or not it
should be excluded and we know that
under 404 that this type of evidence is
only going to be included if we show
that it had something to do with motive
or intent and i don't think that that's
going to happen here and the other thing
is obviously we have 10 other victims
who will be ready willing and able to
testify because their claims are in the
case so i don't think we're going to see
evidence of this additional witness or
victim who has now her claim has been
thrown out yeah that's a typical 404 b
argument we're always talking about the
anagram that we use or the acronym is
mimic um motive intense mistake or lack
of or a common schema plan it could be
one of those things but we'll have to
wait and see judge chris part of the
reason the judge threw out the case was
that the prosecution did not tell the
jury this alleged crime happened outside
of the statute of limitations how
serious a mistake is that well if there
were only one charge it'd be a real
serious mistake but in the grand scheme
of things with all those other charges
it's not going to end up having him
spend one day less in prison
yeah there's still plenty of allegations
plenty of alleged victims there just
will be one fewer and one fewer charge
so we'll see how that case continues as
it progresses in los angeles thank you
both
now to connecticut where a 22 year old
is accused of stabbing and murdering her
grandmother and her grandmother's
boyfriend
soaking wet with water and blood is how
an officer described harley swolls when
they arrived at the scene of the crime
the officers responded to a call from a
neighbor who reported disturbing sounds
coming from the home
victims 63 year old james bell and 72
year old mary rach were found with
multiple stab wounds to their necks and
backs swoles is charged with two counts
of murder in connection with the
stabbing but is claiming self-defense
coming up on law and crime daily is
robert durst now pointing the finger at
an alternative suspect for the murder of
his best friend
plus a jury's verdict for a man
convicted of shooting a sheriff's deputy
at point blank will it be life in prison
or the death penalty for stephen wiggins
find out next
[Music]
welcome back a tennessee man is
sentenced to death for killing a
sheriff's deputy and lining his body on
fire
upon the verdict of the jury finding you
stephen joshua wiggins to be guilty of
murder in the first degree as charged in
the indictment and upon further the
verdict of the jury fixing the
punishment is death
in less than two hours a jury voted
stephen wiggins deserves to be executed
it is therefore ordered that you shall
be put to death by lethal injection in
the mode prescribed by law wiggins was
convicted of the murder of dickinson
county sergeant daniel baker wiggins
shot baker three times stole his police
cruiser then set fire to it with baker
still inside
we get it
baker's wife says she's relieved she
never has to worry about wiggins being
released from prison you know it's been
a long
journey
that
feeling that
he's going to be held accountable
wiggins was also convicted of
impersonating baker after the murder
responding to radio traffic saying 10-4
wanting custody as wiggins was taken
away from the courthouse deputies made
that same call over the radio this time
it was wiggins that was in custody
daniel baker
500 have one in custody from this
location
here with us discuss the death sentence
of stephen wiggins is judged susan chris
and co-host terry austin terry are you
surprised that none of the defense's
arguments got even one person to go
against the death penalty or does this
make perfect sense
well i was a little surprised but it
does make perfect sense brian no doubt
about it the defense attorney did a
great job pleading for wigan's life but
the jury got it right they looked at
these five aggravating factors and each
and every one they said applied here
they said it was a violent feminine that
he had beforehand they said it was
especially heinous atrocious and cruel
they said he tried it to avoid
prosecution when this murder occurred
they said that it was with a law
enforcement officer which we know
law enforcement officer and also they
said that he knowingly mutilated the
body after the body was dead so the jury
thought long and hard about this and
they said that each of these factors
occurred and that all of these
aggravating factors outweigh the
mitigating factors and they sentence him
to death
well terry thinks they thought about it
long and hard i definitely would agree
with the hard part but judge chris
you've presided over a lot of trials
little over an hour to convict under two
hours to sentence when you look at the
facts of this case
does that surprise you
the guilt the guilt part didn't because
they really didn't contest the guilt
there was no question that this wasn't
who did it he did it and he admitted he
did it but the but the punishment there
was so much compelling evidence about
his mental health and his abuse of uh
childhood and extreme extreme abuse and
brain injury and brain damage i thought
it would give them pause to at least
talk about it a little bit longer yeah
but not a single pause just two hours
sorry less than two hours to convict
terry i would have thought maybe someone
had a family member with mental health
issues someone had a family member who
went through young abuse that would have
given them pause but that didn't happen
here right
that's right just one person really
could have stopped this whole death
sentence but i think that each of them
agreed with the others that yes this was
a death sentence case so that was
probably a very quick agreement as i
said it only took under two hours thank
you both for contributing when we come
back where was robert durst the night of
his best friend's murder a phone call
that possibly puts a mystery person in
the house the night that susan berman
died
now to california where real estate air
robert durst takes the stand to tell his
new version of what happened in december
2000
three deaths kathy durst morris black
and now susan berman prosecutors say all
three have one common factor robert
durst while the real estate heir
maintains his innocence he is now on
trial for the murder of his best friend
susan berman berman allegedly knew
information about his missing wife kathy
on the stand durst now says he had
vacation plans with berman that december
putting him near the scene of the crime
had you made plans
before all this
to spend christmas with susan berman
yeah
what were your plans
for susan berman and christmas
i was going to meet her on december 22nd
and we were going to do a staycation
in los angeles
she wanted to do all the things
that tourists do when they
go to los angeles
durst then goes on to describe a phone
call between him and berman potentially
putting someone else in the house the
night that she was murdered
and twice
she interrupted our conversation
to talk to somebody
did you hear who she was talking to hear
anybody else no
did you hear what she said
no
and before durst was on the trial for
the murder of susan berman he was also
accused of the death of his texas
neighbor morris black a crime he has
since been acquitted for durst
originally fled to texas to escape media
attention and disguise himself as a
woman leading to this peculiar line of
questioning from the defense
how did you keep it on how did you keep
it from falling off
a rope
give my answer
wigs come with a
with a rubber liner on the inside
and as long as you don't
shake your head so
vigorously
the wig tends to stay on
well if you're jogging
your head's moving pretty vigorously
that's we're getting a little bit off
track now i i was curious about that
can you let your curiosity
go for one more question
all right
how did you keep it on while you're
jogging
well i did
okay
excuse me while i adjust my hair just
quickly it's not a wig i promise back
with us is judge susan chris who
probably dealt with similar questions
given that she presided over the morris
black case just chris given give us a
glimpse into durst's mind the other
woman who are we are hearing for the
first time do you think um
this other woman is a real factor made
up or the other person sorry
absolutely made up for one thing all
these years and he's never sold anybody
before now second of all he has to make
somebody up he has to explain
how he could have written the note
and found the body but he's not the one
who killed her he has to have an
explanation and this is what he's come
up with
so terry this is what he's come up with
we've got our very own residential
robert durst
expert the judge who presided on his
former case
durst said that this person interrupted
berman a number of times do you think
this could be an alternative suspect
that the defense runs with are we going
to hear from them again or do you think
they'll just kind of let it lay and see
what the jury decides
well let's just say the guern is doing
his job here he is trying very hard to
raise reasonable doubt and he is putting
in this person that as the judge said
we've never even heard of before and so
if the jury believes that maybe someone
else was in the room with susan berman
then in fact that could be something
that would raise some doubt i don't know
if it's reasonable doubt the other
inference that has been made throughout
this trial is that maybe susan berman
was killed by a mafia person because her
father was involved in the mafia i don't
know how much evidence that has been put
into evidence for this trial but that's
certainly a question that has come up
and maybe that will be argued at the end
of the day so
we might just have one person there who
thinks that somebody else could have
done it and as we saw durst can be very
charming well we know that one person
doesn't believe him for sure and that's
prosecutor john lewin definitely
expecting and excited to see that
cross-examination thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you